history and the president are all
intermingled into one we know for a fact
that laborers and enslaved people on pre
emancipation were living in these cabins
but we also know they were used as guest
houses in more recent times and then in
some cases they would use as trash dumps
in even more recent times
so we get all of that trash of material
sort of mixed in together the beauty of
it is that it allows us to sort of look
around and analyze the entire spectrum
of life on the estate in the 1800's
enslaved Africans were brought into the
ports of Christiansted on the Caribbean
island of st. Croix about a hundred
forty enslaved people were forced to
work on a state little princess a sugar
plantation and rum factory the project
that the estate little princess really
began as a terrestrial archaeology
component to a slave wrecks project and
the idea was that we would have a
terrestrial archaeology site and a
maritime archaeology site that could
both speak to the slave trade from
different perspectives while the
terrestrial archaeology has been
forthcoming we haven't been so
forthcoming in terms of locating a
shipwreck to tell that sort of maritime
perspective overall it's been good
because it's been providing new
information and new insight into ways
that maritime resources are actually
used on terrestrial landscapes so
aspects such as coral mining that was
used for housing construction and then
also some of the shellfish and one fish
of course that we use this provisions on
the island still trying to understand
how this landscape has changed over time
is one of my main questions the island
itself is borderline on its ability to
provide enough water for that many
plantations Europeans who came here
along with others removed a lot of the
surface vegetation so that they could
clear spaces to cultivate sugar when all
those trees are removed then the natural
soil deposition and also water regimes
are changed across the entire island
those kind of changes are visible on the
landscape even still because even though
there's not sugar widespread cultivation
on Island it's changed the possible
plants that could actually live there it
really allows us to think about how
inside Africa
we're using plant material and that's
important because in the archaeological
record a lot of those don't don't appear
mainly because they go away but if we
have access to the plants that are still
growing today we can begin to think
about how these plants may have been
used by storm populations in the past
fewer people are talking about actually
environmental reparations and what does
it look like when we talk about
reparations in a context that has been
completely decimated by the slave trade
of my slavery we're looking at increased
Shirley Roshan as a result of these
clear-cutting of forests we're looking
at increased wave turbidity at the
destruction of these coral reefs and
that's something that doesn't just grow
back over a 10 20 and 50 years in
addition to surveying the environment
researchers are speaking with the
community and using historical records
to better understand the occupation of
enslaved people on a state little
princess we don't have a 100% clear
understanding of the full range of
occupation we know that the first parcel
that became a state little princess was
purchased in 1749 and that it was only
11 or 13 acres right now it's more than
30 acres so those maps show that up to
30 cabins existed in the area where
we're excavating of course we've only
found the remains of four by the 60s
there was a really sustained effort for
individuals to stop living in those
cabins unless they were working for the
property owner from our perspective
today it seems improbable or illogical
to stay in the place where slavery was
taking place but for folks who were
freed they didn't have a whole lot of
options there weren't guarantees that if
they left st. Croix they were gonna find
a better life somewhere else
focusing in on the humanity of the
enslaved people is central to their
research goals there's a way that people
are obsessed on that scholars have
become obsessed with numbers and if we
can pinpoint the exact amount of people
that came from this place this place in
this place if we had the exact amount of
glass of ceramic of fauna if we could
compile these in these databases and it
can give us this greater image of what
enslaved life was like but ultimately if
we're just talking about things and we
actually miss the human aspect of it it
can be really dangerous so thinking
about agencies this way of ensuring that
we're talking about humans and that
we're thinking about various levels of
agency all under the umbrella of
enslavement so very complex questions
and explorations but certainly worth
diving into to really say out loud that
although these people were enslaved that
they actually moved through this world
and made choices under that regime about
how they live their lives about how they
built community with each other about
how they love themselves and others the
artifacts on st. Croix helped tell these
stories of agency and resilience we
recovered a perforated shell here at the
site and we've recovered a number of
smaller finds that could have been used
in a dormant practices like glass beads
from button ceramic buttons hook and eye
fasteners so these small fines that
speak to this larger dynamics address at
the same
the fact that we're finding not just
porcelain but hand painted porcelain at
a State little princess tell something
about access an agency and the movement
of goods between communities on this
island so even though they're living
inland they're nowhere near the town
they're able to participate in the
economy in a different way than we might
have thought of before they are not just
there waiting for you know someone to
break something so they can get a
hand-me-down they are actively procuring
their own wares as a purification they
would have a limestone block and they'd
you know perch that somewhere and the
limestone block has properties that is a
natural purifier so they literally run
water through the stone and then it
would drip through the limestone into a
large storage vessels the APRA crucian
rare so they're taking that same pottery
but they're literally creating a system
to purify their own water because there
have been blocked from access to
cisterns from the Europeans are mainly
using and they are relegated to use in
these free guts that are highly
contaminated because everyone's using it
for water for cleaning for livestock for
bathing for any any purpose you can
imagine they came up with a way to solve
that themselves we're really interested
in really understanding what they went
through and what they survived what they
what they see is their expression their
identity their their culture and their
community beyond just looking at the
artifacts beyond just looking at that
status of being enslaved we want to be
able to tell the most complete story we
can with the bits of pieces that we have
to tell that
you